choc de la mairie les chiottes de la
mairie
c'est vrai que les scores d'audience on
fout en ce moment mais on va quand même
refaire un très très très gros points
sur les i gingn alors que j'avais
convoqué la productrice tout à l'heure à
julie raynaud vous dis je il a convoqué
ce soir à tous c'est la nouvelle
productrice elle est formidable dans les
jolis jolis on va vous la présenter en
paix sans humain voilà je vous le dirai
tout mais je vais l'a convoqué à la fin
de la sur mon match c'est très simple
les questions doit apparaître dans
l'écran où tu réponds ou bien tu bois
chouette alors ça peut être bon ça peut
ne pas être bien d'être une bon oui
c'est possible moyens
il ya des trucs qui passe non qui passe
à tout est dégueulasse tout est plutôt
des gains au caire tat le pmp vingtaine
d'attaqués pmp au bar du coin
alors on y va première question et le
hasard a fait quel est pour toi
matt est ce que tu as déjà fait l'amour
sur une de tes chansons si oui laquelle
tout est tellement way jamais ah ouais
non jamais par contre moi j'ai déjà fait
l'amour sur une de tes chansons c'est
vrai à laquelle une photo de toi
elle me contrôle pas elle me contrôler
non non non plus non mais paraît que tu
as déjà fait des préliminaires sur du
johnny or que tu as dit non alors je
j'ai vu ce truc-là sortir ses interviews
que j'ai fait à quelques semaines où on
ne pose des questions la chanson pour
les préliminaires la chanson machin mais
pas et moi c'est pas en rapport avec moi
c'est ce que je pense par rapport aux
paroles et saâles que je t'aime de
johnny qui importe
j'ai déjà fait la route sûre c'est bon
pour le moral de la compagnie connaît
donc vu qu'on est si j'ai répondu c'est
toi qui va alors non
au moins maintenant cyril avoue déjà
fait l'amour devant une de vos émissions
si oui pourquoi mais pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi alors franchement non
impossible même celles qui valait 35
heures impossibles c'est comme ça c'est
impossible avec les villages marcon il
m'arrive un truc et je le raconte dans
la vérité et je crois que voulait déjà
dit un jour je me rappelle que j'ai
animé le morning live sur m6 et j'avais
rencontré une meuf et on était en voilà
en train et un moment et à un moment
elle m'a fait comme ça c'est toujours
que c'est vrai ça m'a fait oui mon ning
live
[Rires]
deux semaines après les sorties avec
moctar ouane a dit oh oui motus c'est
bien sûr qu'ils réveillent voisin en
question pour matt
merci merci d'être matelas dernière fois
que vous avez menti c'était acquis et
pour éviter quoi a dit la vérité si ça
m'a dit tu peux le dire
[Rires]
sinon tu peux boire c'était beaucoup si
c'étaient ses invités elle sourit il a
une idée il ait dit non non c'était
c'était c'était c'était pour il ya trois
minutes connue non je le redis ça
c'était pour des essais pour mon
tournage de film là que je commence dans
un mois c'était des essais de jeu
pourquoi et j'ai dit que je dis que
j'avais j'avais j'avais mal au dos un
truc comme ça je rentrais juste de
belgique j'étais fatigué non mais là il
a dit la vérité
on le voit il faut absolument pas boire
tout court s'il reste vous pouvez lire à
haute voix
le dernier opus ben voilà dark ah oui
alors je vais dire laisse moi je les
connais tu vois non mais tu me laisses
mais je vous le jure
c'est un texto de la productrice ah
ouais ça m a vendu que tu peux lire tu
peux lire vas-y tu peux lire très beau
gosse ton pote pokora je veux bien lui
lancer sa fusée
[Applaudissements]
raynaud maman julie bravo
la démission bravo julie bravo mon mari
regarde et messieurs célibataire a alors
sonné on vous déjà eu des relations
intimes avec un lieu dans un lieu public
si oui où
et ni la vérité oui où ça dans un parc
quel parc informatique en allemagne
allemagne le choc à baden baden baden du
coût des vérités je pensais strasbourg
et à montbard vacances avec une ex c'est
la banda sortie t'associer parc dans sa
dans un pack battant il est froid hier
il ya plein de verdure de deux brevets
bon oui la journée d'armes depuis son
abandon en fin de journée oui quand même
soyez courageux et aussi grosse voiture
on apprend des trucs pas mal mais je ne
veux absolument pas voir ta mère à une
question pour madame c'est super gênant
il ya des trucs super à la nuit ciel
vous déjà mangé des bouts des doigts a
bien sûr bien sûr mais et gt gt j'ai
déjà fait l'amour dans un parc des
princes devant les gens le parc des
princes oui pendant le match manchester
psg la vraie foi cela attendons des faux
billets alors je ne sais pas on a deux
dernières questions pour match aller
parce que moi la mienne avec louis matte
avez vous déjà renouvelé votre slip ou
faut chausser vérité c'est qu'en fait
d'exploit mais elle est déjà passée au
cas où vous aviez des doutes depuis
quinze fichman ont acquis les parts sont
là des invités je vous dis la vérité je
me sens pas là je sens que bon voilà
c'est vraiment minuit chaque fois qu'il
voit tu crois que c'est un savon gens
maintenant on a envie de te dire on a
envie de se frotter à toiture
j'ai pape a pour nom il a été honnête à
cyril si demain vous nous présenter plus
tpp qui mettriez vous à votre place
alors je vais vous dire un mètre sur
pour être sûr que ça se plante matthieu
delormeau
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]